thank you hi how is that was that was
everybody and again my name is drew
Lynch I stutter I have to say that every
show cuz people look look at me like
does he know you'd actually be surprised
and nothing number of times people come
up and they're like I bet that's not you
your real voice you're just so lately
I've been doing this thing where I just
never mentioned my stutter so when
someone tells me I do I I react like I
didn't know there was a guy who can't
came up like hey man you you were
stuttering up up there I was awesome
I was like
how bad is that
hey was like it it's pretty bad I was
like this is this is just the worst news
you know it's hard enough being black
[Applause]
it was like here you you're not black I
was like wow I'm not really
self-conscious about but about my voices
as I am my height and like I had gone up
to a girl one time and before I could
say anything she was like you're too
short and I was like well well people
seem to enjoy life and and they say
that's too short
then she almost reacted like like I
chose to be this height like I used to
be taller and I was like well this is
well this is much too high for me and
then I started running around outside
until a turtle shell hit me and I you
know just looking for a mushroom now
even on dating apps like doesn't the
first question a girl will message you
should like how how tall are you
and I'm like five four and then they
don't respond so I gotta be like three
two two one
[Laughter]
[Applause]
met a girl one time who's like yeah I
only date guys who are taller than me
and I'm gonna wear that's like if I said
well I'm only gonna date girls who are
shorter than me and I'm gonna amputate
my legs why do you need me to be that
for you
well because I need to feel like you are
you're tall she's like what how bad
[Applause]
you